[Music]
hey
will you stop shouting you're scaring
the bears
i'm sorry what the bears
you're scaring them stop making those
those noises
this exchange happened at a zoo in
anchorage alaska
in august of 2014.
now to be clear this woman's
unsolicited feedback wasn't an
aberration
from the norm for me i was diagnosed
in sixth grade so i've had to deal with
interactions like these for
most of my life the timing
of this particular exchange though it
stung
and it stung because it happened at the
tail end of one of the most
transformative summers
of my life i had spent the
70 days leading up to that afternoon
biking more than 4 000 miles on a
bicycle not a motorcycle
from austin texas to anchorage alaska
the world's longest charity bike ride
around every switchback in the ozarks
through every cornfield in the midwest
and
up every peak in the canadian rockies
i listened to stories
stories shared with me by my teammates
as we rode
stories shared by host families in their
living rooms
and stories shared by complete strangers
in gas station parking lots
their stories inspired me to reflect
on my own and it was through that
deep hard reflection that i learned
how to love my story now
i'm still figuring out how to tell my
story
but i made a lot of progress that summer
progress that the woman from the zoo
couldn't have been more disinterested in
no she was worried about the bears
tourette's is a neurological condition
characterized by
involuntary vocal outbursts or motor
spasms called
ticks and it typically stems from
dysfunctional
basal ganglia a group of subcortical
nuclei
buried deep in the cerebral hemispheres
of the brain
responsible in part for motor and vocal
decision
making now for those of you who don't
have tourette's
and statistically speaking that's the
majority of you
let me break that down
think about the last time you were
working in a quiet coffee shop
chances are you didn't break the silence
in that coffee shop
by shouting unintentionally
think about the last time you were
taking handwritten notes
either in class or on a call
chances are you didn't put pen to paper
with such unintentional force
that the pens inc bled through the page
think about the last time you were hand
in hand
with someone else be it a friend
a family member or a romantic partner
chances are you didn't send
guilt-inducing
pain through that person's hand
by unintentionally squeezing their
fingers
in between yours and the reason you
didn't do
any of these things is because the
nuclei
in your basal ganglia are sending
inhibitory
signals through the thalamus and into
the cerebral cortex
to suppress those unwanted actions
you can picture the nuclei saying don't
shout at the coffee shop
don't slam the pen down
don't squeeze their fingers
i on the other hand have done these
things
in fact i still do a lot of these things
today you see
my brain isn't quite as reliable
at suppressing those unwanted actions
tourette's is tricky in that there's
still
a lot that the medical community doesn't
know
about the condition primarily because it
shows up
in disparate and nuanced ways
ticks certainly aren't consistent across
folks with tourette's
and seldom are they consistent for a
single person
with tourette's i woke up
one morning in middle school making
hiccup-like noises i couldn't control
these hiccups grew in both intensity
and frequency and were eventually
accompanied
by throat clearing
and nose blowing
i've had more than two dozen types of
ticks
since i was diagnosed some have come and
gone
others have remained inconveniently
loyal
middle school was pretty forlorn for me
as if the psychological and biological
turmoil that characterizes puberty
wasn't enough as is
i had been thrown the world's nastiest
curveball
and rather than squaring my shoulders to
home plate
and swinging at that curveball
i stepped away from the batter's box
because that was the easy thing to do
i relinquished my seat at the front of
the classroom
i walked along the edges of the hallways
in complete silence
and i declined invitations to birthday
parties
which were admittedly far and few
between for a middle schooler with
tourette's
because i didn't want the few friends i
did have
knowing just how different i was
i just wanted to feel like i belonged
we all do right
three years after my diagnosis my mom
sat me down the summer before i started
high school
and said kevin i know middle school was
tough
but high school doesn't have to be that
way
you can keep living under this rock and
i know that's the safe
and comfortable thing to do and no one
would blame you for it
or you can climb to the top of that rock
and start owning the things that make
you
you my mom was right
i have tourette's but tourette's doesn't
have
me tourette's is one of many parts of me
and it's a part of me i've grown to
appreciate
over the years you know
there's a lot that makes you you
as well neurodiversity
refers to the many intricate and complex
ways
in which the human brain differs from
one person to the next
sometimes those differences are subtle
and
other times they are frustratingly
pronounced
but they're always there and they
always make us stronger
and it's for that reason that each of us
has a vested interest in creating a
world
in which neurodiversity our differences
are both appreciated and celebrated
and there are three things that we can
do together
today and every day
to help cultivate that world
to help normalize what is truly
quite normal
first question
first impressions
by definition they're based off limited
sets of data as humans
we are wired to categorize people places
and things
safe or not safe same
or different likable
or not likeable now i'm not asking you
to refrain from having first impressions
or making snap judgments altogether
i am however asking you to question
their accuracy and in doing so
whether you know it or not you are
acknowledging
that there is always more to someone's
story
which leads me to point number two
learn someone's story learn everyone's
story and learn stories by having tough
conversations
by asking thoughtful questions
by doing research and sharing what you
learn
with others learning stories
can be hard it can be taxing and
exhausting
and time consuming but it is
always worth it so
roll up your sleeves and put in the time
and read other people's stories with
grace
and empathy with compassion
and curiosity you might just learn
something
and third actively expand
your in-group we're inherently drawn to
folks
who are similar to us we find
immense amounts of comfort in
homogeneity
but we learn and grow when we're
surrounded by folks
who aren't like us when we're surrounded
by folks
who look act think pray love
and yes even navigate zoos
differently than we do
so lean into that discomfort
embrace that uncertainty push those
boundaries everyone wants to feel
like they belong so let's make them
feel like they belong
if someone came up to me today
and said that with a wave of their magic
wand
they could send me back to sixth grade
and i could live my life
free of tourettes i wouldn't consider it
not even for a second sure
it'd be more convenient but having
tourette's has shaped who i am as a
person
it's colored the lens through which i
view the world
and it's informed how i treat the people
i'm lucky enough to navigate
this beautifully diverse world with
you might scare the bears every now and
then and that's okay
your story is uniquely yours
and my story is uniquely mine
so let's keep writing and sharing our
stories
with this world and let's do that
[Applause]
[Music]
together